vor allem wenn wir auf die letzten drei
Jahre blicken wir sagen jetzt heute ist
zumindest der Tag dass die Maske fällt
aber es war für ganz ganz viele brutal
Menschen sind einsam gestorben dürften
ihre Verwandten nicht mehr sehen in
ihren letzten Stunden Kinder saßen
allein und isoliert zu Hause hat
niemanden mit dem sie spielen dürfen
konnten die Schulen nicht besuchen
Existenzen gingen zugrunde das alles
sind die Konsequenzen für ganz ganz
viele Menschen und genau mit diesen
Menschen beschäftigen sie sich jetzt da
sind wir auch direkt drin in ihrem
Zimmer ich möchte dazu noch einsetzen
Karl Lauterbach hat heute gesagt ja
diese drakonischen Maßnahmen über die
wir jetzt auch gerade gesprochen haben
also ausgehverbote Masken tragen an der
freien Luft Kinderspielplätze draußen
absperren das sind Dinge gewesen die
würde man heute nicht mehr machen das
geht ihnen nicht weit genug das ist auch
keine Entschuldigung das geht aber auch
ganz vielen Menschen die brutal gelitten
haben nicht weit genug und genau um
diese Menschen können Sie sich jetzt mit
einer Sammelklage erklären Sie uns
einmal was es damit auf sich hat und was
Sie erreichen wollen
die Lage ist ja das ist ja das falsche
Wort sowas haben wir in Deutschland
nicht und das ist auch erstmal nicht
nicht der Punkt wir haben
ja was ja vollkommen richtig gerade
angesprochen wurde gesehen dass das
vollkommen aus dem Ruder gelaufen ist
der wie man ja auch in dem Einspieler
sieht da da laufen Leute im Schnee mit
einer Maske durch die Gegend und und
wollen Kinder dafür bestrafen dass er
ohne Maske auf dem Schlitten in der
Gegend rumfahren und dass das zu dem
Zeitpunkt keinem absurd vorgekommen ist
sondern dass alle brav mitgemacht haben
dass der springende Punkt jetzt stellen
sich die die führenden gestalten hin so
sie sich dann überhaupt noch hinstellen
der Drosten hat sich ja aus der
Gutachterkommission für die Evaluierung
der Maßnahmen Muschi Muschi einfach
zurückgezogen er wollte da nichts mehr
mit zu tun haben Herr Wila will mit dem
RKI nichts mehr zu tun haben und der
Gesundheitsminister der das alles nicht
nur getragen hat sondern ins lauteste
größte Horn gestoßen hat sagt jetzt na
das würden wir heute also das waren ja
drakonische Maßnahmen das waren auch
damals schon dragonische Maßnahmen und
das ist auch von einem erheblichen Teil
der Bevölkerung aus der Wissenschaft
auch von den Juristen alles mögliche
angesprochen worden und man das muss ja
auch sagen öffentlich diffamiert und
angefeindet und sonst irgendwas wurden
die Medien haben sich da auch nicht
unbedingt mit Rum bekleckert so dass wir
eben zunehmend Leute erleben die sagen
wie wollen wir das eigentlich
aufarbeiten politisch
bin ich
skeptisch dass das passieren wird dass
da jemand von alleine Konsequenzen
ziehen wird
gesellschaftlich ist der
Aufarbeitungsprozess ich glaube das ist
natürlicher Prozess der stattfinden wird
und den man glaube ich auch im
juristisch anschieben muss wir haben mit
dem Marcel lute der ja auch schon ein
paar Mal hier war der hat ja eine
Gewerkschaft gegründet und der bietet
sein
Gewerkschaftsmitgliedern an dass wir
evaluieren können wir Schadensersatz
klagen gegen den Staat führen für
Betriebsschließungen dafür dass das
Leute insbesondere Kinder psychische
Störungen entwickelt haben auch etwas
was
aus Richtung der der pädiatischen
Medizin wenn man denn hingehört hätte
noch lauter hätte man es nicht schreien
können das genau das passieren wird wir
haben die auf einmal die Kinderstationen
voll mit Atemwegserkrankungen bei
Kindern was für zweieinhalb Jahren nicht
hatten auch das ist prognostiziert
worden wenn man den Kindern nicht
ermöglicht ich sag mal den Ringtausch
unter dem Ansteckungen durchzuführen
dass die sich dann eine Welle aufbaut
die sich gewaschen hat heute ist
veröffentlicht worden oh wir müssen mit
einer einem Anstieg von Krebsfällen
rechnen weil die Leute sind nicht zur
Vorsorge gehen konnten da war dort
erwartet uns auch etwas und für all
diese Leute auch Leute die
wirtschaftlich ruiniert worden sind
möchten wir erreichen dass da eine
juristische Aufarbeitung stattfindet und
das eben diese Tatsache mal auch auf den
Tisch kommen weil wir da Überzeugung
sind wie gesagt das hätte man nicht nur
wissen können man hätte es wissen müssen
und man hat es in vielen Bereichen so
unsere Überzeugung auch gewusst weil
wenn man sich mal genau anschaut wer
erzählt hat das Masken was bringen dass
die Impfung was bringen Abstand halten
Lockdown alles das sind immer nur Leute
die unmittelbar oder mittelbar vom Staat
abhängig gewesen sind und von ihm Geld
bekommen haben und außerhalb außerhalb
dieser Sphäre hat sich ein viel
differenzierteres Meinungsbild
gezeichnet das gibt ja jetzt sogar der
der Gesundheitsminister dazu dass das so
ist und wir wollen erreichen dass wir
diese Fakten vor einem Gericht auf den
Tisch bringen Beweisverfahren
durchführen und dann auf der Grundlage
entscheidend ist hier nicht nur ich sag
mal verfassungswidrig gehandelt worden
sondern wenigstens fahrlässig
verfassungswidrig gehandelt worden
sprich Anzahlung und
staatshaftungsansprüche direkt gegen den
Strom wer sind die Menschen die zu
kommen was sind das für Geschichten die
sie auch dort erfahren für Schicksale
die sie dort erfahren und was wollen Sie
erreichen also für uns alle nicht
Juristen was kann man da erreichen hohe
Geldstrafen oder was stellen Sie vor in
erster Linie natürlich
Schadensersatzzahlungen vom vom Staat an
den Bürgern
es gibt aber natürlich auch um ich sag
mal eine gewisse Form von Genugtuung für
die Leute dass das Geld ist für die
Leute tatsächlich an der Stelle sekundär
das ist auch das was was zu äh zunehmend
an uns herangetragen wird das sind Leute
die zum Beispiel diffamiert worden sind
Leute die die aus gesundheitlichen
Gründen nicht am impfen lassen können wo
halt wirklich alle Ärzte gesagt haben
geht nicht Leute die aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen keine Maske
tragen konnten Leute die den der der der
Laden zugemacht wurde und die von den
vor ihrem Ruin steht stehen und die sich
dann hat auch noch dafür beleidigen
lassen müssen dass sie gegen den
Anführungszeichen die corona-maßnahmen
gegen die corona-politik gewesen sind
und das die wollen sich eben nicht
abspeisen lassen mit auch entschuldigung
das haben wir alles nicht gewusst
man muss eben auch die die Frage
beantworten können und diese Frage kann
politisch kann aber Antworten wenn man
es nicht hätte wissen können warum gab
es dann Leute die es gewusst haben ganz
präzise voraus haben voraussagen können
wie sich das entwickeln wird was
passieren wird und welche Schäden
dadurch eintreten dass das quasi von
Stunde Null was kann das im Einzelfall
bedeuten das klingt irgendwie wenn man
es versucht zusammenzufassen und zu
bündelnder strafen in Milliardenhöhe bis
zum Teil was können Sie das greifbar
machen natürlich sind die sind die
Schäden die da angerichtet worden sind
wenn man es mal aufsummieren wollte
tatsächlich in der in der Größenordnung
wir gehen nicht davon aus dass so viele
Leute tatsächlich in Anführungszeichen
sich juristisch so sehr dagegen wehren
wollen dass der Staat dann dass der
Staat dann Milliarden und aber
Milliarden zahlen muss an dem Schritt
sind wir auch noch nicht wir wollen plus
eine Möglichkeit haben für die Leute die
sagen ich möchte das jetzt ich möchte
jetzt wissen
Beweisverfahren durchzuführen also als
als Vorstufe von der eigentlichen
schadensersatzlage wo man sich eben vor
dem Gericht trifft und sagt so wir holen
jetzt erstmal die Fakten auf dem Tisch
und Sachverständige die uns Gutachten
dazu erstellen die uns dann sagen können
was hat man gewusst was hätte man wissen
können und was hätte man wissen müssen
was ist eigentlich der wissenschaftliche
Status Quo weil das möchte ich noch mal
noch mal deutlich machen weil ja auch
Asien angesprochen wurde wir wissen von
dort was machst du tragen bringt nämlich
jemanden Community Setting gar nichts
wenn die Leute in der in der Bahn oder
am Arbeitsplatz oder so eine Maske
tragen dann das hat überhaupt überhaupt
keinen Effekt Krankenhaus andere
Geschichte wo die wo die Leute trainiert
sind eine Maske zu tragen dass sie
abschließend sitzt aber wenn ich mir
anschaue dass die Leute die Maske in die
Tasche gesteckt haben und wieder
rausgeholt haben und aufgesetzt haben
die Maske
Friedrich der anschließen wollen Sie
Antworten auf diese absolut also die
Politik ist uns eine Antwort schuldig
muss ich entschuldigen wir müssen auch
die Gräten zwischen den Menschen mit der
schließen und Brücken bauen die
Kollateralschäden die in den letzten
drei Jahren geschehen sind sind
gigantisch und ich glaube das ist fast
so wie oft in West damals also wirklich
die Vermehrung die Stigmatisierung
Menschen haben ihre Existenz verloren
Kinder haben keine Bildung genießen
können und so weiter sind Billionen
wahrscheinlich und wir wurden wirklich
sind das nicht gefühlt wir würden
angelogen töten Fall bewiesen das Pfeife
direkt auch Leute die cancelt hat auf
Twitter das bei uns hat gesagt wir
müssen die Kritiker rausnehmen es ist
ein Ding und wie gesagt Lauterbach muss
eigentlich die Faktor zurücktreten wir
brauchen Entschuldigung um hier bitte
zusammenzukommen als Gesellschaft was
hier passiert ist ist eigentlich der
größte Skandal der des neuen
Jahrtausenden Twitter falls vieles wird
aber gar nicht ja sozusagen in Geld
messbar sein auf zu wiegen sein es ist
natürlich unmöglicher Hawks was bedeutet
das vor allem für junge Menschen auch
für Jugendliche Menschen auch in
Österreich waren die Maßnahmen besonders
hart da hat man eine Strafe
beispielsweise bekommen wenn man Sport
im Park gemacht hat mit mehr als zwei
oder drei Personen dann gab es eine
Geldstrafe und so was bedeutet das für
eine ganze junge Generation die Jahre so
verbringen musste zu der ersten Studien
rausgekommen dass man immer geschaut hat
wie geht's den Menschen psychologisch
jetzt danach und es scheint so als wären
bei den meisten keine bleibenden Schäden
entstanden nur bei der jüngeren
Generation bei der Generation zählt also
die die genau in diesem Alter wo man
vielleicht ein bisschen abkoppelt vom
Elternhaus versucht die Welt zu erkunden
auch Selbstwirksamkeit zum ersten Mal
erfährt genau zu dem Alter wurde das
geklappt ja und die brauchen jetzt Hilfe
das muss man schlicht und ergreifen zu
sagen also die sind natürlich jetzt
einerseits in den sozialen Fähigkeiten
ein bisschen gehemmt und andererseits
haben sie natürlich das zentrale
Erlebnis des Erwachsenen werdens genau
in diesem Übergang haben Maturaball also
Abschluss der Schule und so weiter das
haben die alles verpasst das sind
natürlich wichtige Entwicklungsschritte
und dem muss man jetzt unter die Arme
greifen ja die haben ja aufgrund von
vielen verschiedenen Dynamiken
Demografie Einkommen wo ich das
Verteilung und so weiter sowieso schon
relativ schwierige Karten und jetzt noch
das oben drauf ist natürlich sehr sehr
belastend und da ist davon auszugehen
dass man den wirklich auch
psychologische Hilfe bieten werden muss
weil die nächste Generation trägt
natürlich die Wirtschaft Deutschlands
und nehmen aber da die Politik eher aus
der Verantwortung wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe weil der so ein bisschen
Unterstützung muss kommen aber sie haben
nicht die harten drängenden Fragen die
Frage wer steht sich da die
Verantwortung auch ein wer zieht
Konsequenzen beispielsweise Politik ist
zu langsam das ist das Problem keine
Erwartungen ich bin halt da nicht
verblendet also meines Erachtens war das
einzige wirklich positiv an der Pandemie
weil die Zivilgesellschaft nicht die
Politik und da muss man auch Stärken
spielen und nicht auf Schwächen aber da
haben wir ja auch erschreckende
Beispiele gesehen also ich meine ich
habe mich immer gefragt wie konnte
eigentlich Hitler an die Macht kommen
jetzt muss ich sagen durch letzten drei
Jahre habe ich es gesehen und was auch
gar nicht angesprochen wurde wobei was
hier angesprochen haben die
Übersterblichkeit wo kommt die auf
einmal her dann können wir haben 32%
übersterblich gehabt im letzten
Dezemberwoche in in in Großbritannien
sind 11% vor allem auch bei jungen
Frauen also es ist ein Katastrophe wo
ist es dir Impfung da müssen wir
Obduktion durchführen ist es Corona
Corona ist es anscheinend nicht weil
beim kommen noch inzidenzzahlen und
diese Übersterblichkeit macht mir große
Sorgen wenn wir jetzt 32 %
Übersterblichkeit hatten in der letzten
Dezemberwoche in Deutschland und die
Zahlen letztes Jahr waren bei über 20%.
also wir haben hier eigentlich nicht
getesteten Impfstoff auf die Menschheit
losgelassen deswegen Experiment gewesen
und wir waren die Kaninchen macht ihnen
das an Angst diese Übersterblichkeit
auch beispielsweise kubiki aus der FDP
hat gefordert man müsste mehr
Obduktionen durchführen bei Menschen die
in einem Zeitraum nach der Impfung
gestorben sind
dass Deutschland sehr wenig Obduktion
macht das muss man sagen das sind die
Österreicher ein bisschen weiter vorne
grundsätzlich ist es aber so man merkt
schon ich bin kein Mediziner es gibt da
doch auch sehr intelligente Menschen mit
medizinischer Bildung die das
Aufarbeiten werden ja also wir sehen es
ja auch bei ihrem Beispiel die
Aufarbeitung wird es die große Frage
sein ich würde mir nicht anmaßen
erklären zu wollen weswegen die
Übersterblichkeit des stattfindet das
wird garantiert ein multifaktorielles
System oder ein multifaktoriellen Grund
haben und so früh schon und mit dem
Finger zu zeigen und zu sagen daran muss
es liegen dass treibt die Diskussion
natürlich weg von einer ergebnisoffen in
einer Ergebnis geschlossene Diskussion
und dann kommen wir wahrscheinlich nie
auf die wahre Ursachen aber ich glaube
dass das macht macht auch machen auch
nur wenige Leute die halt wirklich sagen
das muss zum Beispiel die Impfung sein
es geht ja nicht um die Frage jetzt
schon sagen zu können was es ist bloß
wenn ich mir überlege wie wenig in den
letzten zweieinhalb Jahren Pandemie an
wissenschaftliche Evidenz nämlich quasi
überhaupt keiner dem Staat ausgereicht
hat die schwerwiegendsten und
weitreichendsten Grundrechtseingriffe in
der Nachkriegsgeschichte Deutschlands zu
verordnen und jetzt liegt da so ein so
ein es ist ja nicht mal nicht mal mehr
der elefante im Raum steht das ist die
gesamte Elefanten hier die im Raum steht
dass da irgendwas nicht stimmen kann und
der Staat stellt sich für
weiß ich eigentlich auch nicht krank
geworden
eindimensionale Erklärung für
offensichtlich multifaktorelle
zusammen dass man genauer hinschaut es
geht jetzt nicht darum eine Lösung zu
finden direkt an diesen Tisch das werden
wir heute nicht schaffen aber es geht
darum genauer hinzuschauen und auch die
Stimmen zu hören die während der
Pandemie zu wenig gehört wurden das wird
in jetzt auch eingestanden viele sagen
ja das gibt's das müssen wir Geier diese
Aufarbeitung Sebastian weit genug muss
die Politik an diesen Schrauben mal
stärker drehen sich dem Meer stellen das
wird ja gar nicht richtig aufgearbeitet
viele haben ja auch ein Interesse daran
dass eben nicht aufgearbeitet wird ich
fand es zum Beispiel sehr erschreckend
wie leicht man offensichtlich in unserem
Land rechtsstaatliche Strukturen
aushebeln kann das ist ja passiert und
vielleicht man aber auch den
Parlamentarismus aushebeln kann ja also
das nicht mehr im Parlament beschlossen
wird über solche Maßnahmen sondern dass
in einer Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
diese berühmte MPK schalte dann
irgendwie so im im Hinterzimmer und
nachts quasi irgendwie untereinander was
besprochen wird was dann aber gar nicht
demokratisch letztlich legitimiert ist
durch Politiker mit den entsprechenden
Mandaten das fand ich beides sehr
erschreckend und ich finde auch dieses
Modell dieser sogenannten
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz müsste man
sich insgesamt mal ansehen ob man davon
noch weiter Gebrauch machen will sowas
gehört eigentlich nach meiner Auffassung
ins Parlament damit Leute darüber
entscheiden die von uns auch gewählt
worden sind
also als Jurist und und Freund unserer
Verfassung eigentlich gar nicht gar
nicht genug unterstreichen und das war
auch in den letzten zweieinhalb Jahren
immer wieder ein Argument zu sagen dass
viele von den Regeln nicht mit der
nötigen demokratischen Legitimation
geschlossen worden sind wir haben ein
Bundestag einen Bundesrat eine wir haben
eine Regierung wir haben Landtage
Landesregierungen wir haben ein
Verfassungsgericht das sind alles
Verfassungsorgane die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist ein
verfassungsrechtliches Nullung die
existiert nicht die hat keinerlei
Kompetenz irgendetwas zu entscheiden und
nominell dann Entscheidungen durch
irgendwelche Regierungen durchzuwinken
nachdem hinter verschlossenen Türen wo
niemand eigentlich genau nachvollziehen
kann wer da was mit wem besprochen wurde
an den an der Bundes nicht nur an der
Bundesregierung vorbei sondern an an
Bundestag vorbei Bild haben ja eifrig
reingeleuchtet auch in dieser
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz muss man
sagen sonst müsste man wahrscheinlich
sehr viel werden noch darüber was dort
wer wie eigentlich vertreten hat wer
wollte immer weiter verschärfen der
wollte vielleicht mal lockern wer wurde
wie zurecht gewesen von wem es gibt auch
von ganz oben aus dem Kanzleramt Frau
Merkel wir drücken Virologen die beraten
haben ja heute sind wir alle schlauer da
muss ich sagen damals
und das muss gemacht werden quasi eine
Art von Einflüsterung und manche haben
aber eben auch Politiker dann gesagt ich
bin kein Virologe ich weiß ja nicht
haben nicht richtig abgewogen was
bedeutet das z.B für andere Krankheiten
die Leute gehen nicht so Vorsorge wir
haben es gehört und so weiter und haben
sich nur noch auf Corona irgendwie
fokussiert und alles andere Untertisch
waren lassen und im Ergebnis die
moralische Aufladung ist ein großes
Problem der ist ging ja mitten durch
Onkel Heinz lässt sich nicht impfen der
ist wohl irgend so ein Alu Träger der
ist nicht also
da es wird auch vorbei geimpft es gibt
weiterhin beispielsweise wir haben schon
angesprochene impfpflichte in der
Bundeswehr es gibt weiterhin und darüber
haben wir hier auch bei Bild berichtet
immer mehr Fälle von Impfschäden die
sagen ich habe diese und jede wirklich
gravierende Beschwerden seitdem ist mein
Leben wirklich eingeschränkt halten sie
dem Umgang mit diesem Thema für
gerechtferten ich finde erstens
unverantwortlich dass man weiter impft
wo jetzt doch auch im Schäden sehen und
zwar immer mehr und dafür dass sie
anscheinend sehr sehr selten sind sind
viele Meldungen und viele Reportagen und
viele Beispiele und dahin gehen müssen
darüber Bericht man muss darüber reden
man muss die Impfung erstmal legen um zu
testen was ist überhaupt los also was
für zu den Todesfällen warum haben wir
so viele Krebs Patienten und vor allem
warum haben wir ihm Schäden was ist die
Ursache dafür
auch die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen auf
einmal über die Kliniken die Menschen
mit Impfschäden behandeln sollen voll
sind mit Wartelisten nur die Menschen
keinen Platz finden ja ist doch sicheren
viele wissen nicht woher kommt jetzt
diese Krankheit ist eine
unterschiedlichste Ausführungen die
einen kriegen irgendwie Herpes zoster
die anderen haben ein
Herzmuskelentzündung andere haben dann
anscheinend Turbo Krebs und ist genau
das was sie vorhin gesagt haben einige
Wissenschaftler haben ja vor zwei drei
Jahren genau vor diesen Entwicklungen
gewarnt dass eine Übersterblichkeit
kommt das ist zu Problemen führen wird
weil dieser mRNA Impfstoff einfach nicht
getestet wurde und ihn dann auf die
Menschheit loszulassen und dann auch
noch mit Steuergeldern den zu
finanzieren die Marketing von Preise und
kurz zu übernehmen
und großes Lob aus gesprochen für Bayern
Tag quasi als Retter in der Pandemie wie
kam das bei ihnen persönlichern er nicht
gut weil das Spiel ist noch nicht zu
Ende es geht immer 90 Minuten und wir
sehen ja dass du auch große
Kollateralschäden entstanden sind auch
gesundheitlich nicht nur
gesellschaftlich und Bayern Tag macht ja
auch die Pflege wieder die
Krebsforschung Richtung England aus
Zossen verdient saßen ja auch in
Deutschland an der Goldgrube oder
lustiges Beispiel dass die eine
Goldgrube sitzen in Mainz und jetzt
gehen sie mit nachdem sie Milliarden
verdient haben und das
nicht sein also braucht man auch eine
übergewinnsteuer eigentlich bei biontek
weil wir haben den ganzen Schlamassel
eigentlich finanziert mit Steuergeld und
wir haben das Marketing gemacht es war
eigentlich in der Haftung Null genau das
ist halt auch noch der absolute Hammer
da habe ich auch dazu ein Video mal
gemacht dass er in den EU
geheimverträgen hatten geheimverträgen
muss man sich mal überlegen von der EU
das da drin steht dass die
impf-hersteller geschützt werden vor
allem ein feindungen für Bußgeldern als
auch für irgendwelchen Verfahren dass
die Uhr sich schützend vor diese
Konzerne stellt ich dachte immer die EU
stellt sich vor die Bürger und nicht vor
die Konzerne das heißt wenn was sein
sollte zum Beispiel im Schäden oder
Schadensersatzklagen dann zahlen wir
dafür und es ist doch ein und Ding warum
Geheimverträge erstens dass wir wissen
nicht was haben wir bezahlt ja was sind
die Abmachungen und warum muss dann die
euphester oder Grenzen im moderner und
so weiter schützen und nicht die Bürger
die jetzt darunter leiden